created by ten Studios taking four years
Assassin's Creed unity is the most
innovative leap forward for next-gen
gaming
this video covers all the major features
and technological advancements in
Assassin's Creed unity from the crowds
of 5,000 people in the streets of Paris
to the deep customization of your master
assassin to the debut of four player
co-op welcome to the revolution save a
bullet for yourself the new next-gen
anvil angel brings the city of Paris to
life built near one to one scale with
meticulous detail this beautiful city is
by far the largest in Syria's history
historically accurate designs and fully
detailed interns make you feel like all
really their new dynamic range lighting
illuminates environments with
astonishing realism while next-gen
reflection mapping shines of the wet
cold stones seven diverse districts each
have their own moon architecture and
citizens from the toxic industrial
factories to the science labs and
libraries of the Latin Quarter out on
the streets crowds of over 5,000
characters on screen are all alive in
their own way and intelligently react to
you and our surroundings
the epic scale detail and life built
into the great city of Paris make a
perfect playground for a revolution
let's tell the Royals that our families
must be new
you play as Arno Dorian the deadliest
assassin yet with the power of next-gen
engineering we've overhauled gear combat
stealth and parkour to give you
unprecedented control you can craft
honor in your own personal Master
Assassin tailor every element of his
gear and skills to suit your playstyle
the Phantom blade a modest little update
from the traditional assassin's blade
no to assassins will be the same your
choices will affect every aspect of
battle and your progress in a complete
single-player campaign or carry over
into your co-op missions Touche
a reinvented fighting system provides
more nuanced combat against the smartest
enemies yet put your abilities to the
test
as you'll need to parry dodge and attack
with greater skill timing and flow to
execute the perfect kills enhance
stealth gameplay featuring a brand new
active cover system provide you with new
stock kill and disappear strategies
beware
guards are now smarter too with their
own line of sight they'll even split up
and interrogate citizens as they search
around for your last known location to
better navigate the massive and
intricate buildings we've also added
greater speed and variety to your
parkour abilities full motion control
makes it faster and more fluid than ever
to select different parkour paths on the
flop for the first time in the franchise
you can jump seamlessly into two to four
player co-op at any time certain nations
are too much for any one assassin to
take on alone in those instances many
prefer to work with the same team
consistently each player can play a
unique role in the team there are no
rigid classes but each player can move
their play preferences around preset
frameworks such as stealth melee
ranged or health a well-balanced team is
most effective in column your your
friends will play a huge role in pivotal
moments of the French Revolution
sabotage and execution protect an
emperor assassinate an enemy agent join
up with fellow assassins to pull off the
perfect heist and infiltrate an enemy
stronghold to loot priceless relics
victory won't be easy you and your
lethal value must rely on communication
coordination and divers skills to
accomplish your missions and then vanish
into the shadows new team based special
skills can be shared by one player
across the whole team communal sense
shares eagle vision the ability to
highlight enemies and objectives in the
crowded streets the disguised skill lets
players mask their appearance group
healing shares health regeneration and
the assassin cache creates storage for
team shared bombs and amyl combine these
skills to succeed on the most
challenging mission Napoleon certainly
don't look like a blood-crazed
revolutionary the next gen anvil engines
character design and motion capture have
enabled deeper storytelling and
immersion than ever before there we've
lost you again maybe not let's keep
looking there is unparalleled accuracy
down to the finest detail of hair skin
expressions and mannerisms allowing to
feel and empathize with our aspirations
and struggles encounter famous figures
like Napoleon King Louie and the
eccentric Marquis de Sade Inspira sea
intrigue the rapidly thickening plot add
some bestiality and Electress priest and
I say you have the beginnings of a
beautiful novel I'd settle for a solid
lead last but not least is the only time
anomaly during the campaign Arno will
have to jump through an unstable time
anomaly which will transport him to a
new
in Paris climb the Eiffel Tower and man
machine guns to take down war planes all
during the height of the German
occupation of France during World War
two
let's go we've pushed your new hardware
to the absolute limit to bring you and
your friends the next-gen experience
you've been waiting for so jump into the
stunningly lifelike creation of the
brutal French Revolution craft Arnaud
into your own personal Master Assassin
in either the breathtaking single-player
campaign or in the all-new seamless
co-op take control of your combat and
movement like never before and join us
in making history make history
Assassin's Creed unity pre-order now for
the explosive chemical revolution
mission get a season pass save 30% on
eight hours of new content includes a
new campaign more missions and weapons
and a new downloadable game pre-order
now available November 11th
[Music]